um during the elections our our hero
this dude man our hero i unironically
love and can i just say something
free joe exotic free joe exotic but
i like cardi b no because she's trying
to
literally trying to get this man sprung
and i'm like holy sh
i see eye to eye with cardi b about
something well this is from 2016 this is
from his joe exotic tv
uh this is when he was running for
president
and welcome to video message number 29.
this one goes out once again to all the
presidential candidates and
the politicians and the city council
members and everybody in the united
states as well
as some of you american citizens because
you can learn just as much from these
videos as the politicians can oh yeah
let me start off by saying
in no means during any of these videos
am i
in the united states government oh
that's always a good start
this is already starting great it's
always a great start to a [ __ ] video
just because i wear a firearm i live in
the state of oklahoma and i have a
permit to carry a firearm especially on
my own property
i work very good with the united states
department of agriculture's inspectors i
have never had
anything but a good time working with my
inspector
the problem here is there's a [ __ ]
out there in ohio
called tim harrison runs the
outreach for animals program
a non-profit organization okay but he is
the one that pushed this stupid-ass law
in ohio to take all the people's animals
away i want to point something out he
ran for the governor of oklahoma
and he didn't win but he got 19 of the
vote jesus christ
that's awesome he got close man that's
pretty damn close
from you all right brags to be an ex-cop
a firefighter a paramedic and all that
[ __ ]
and he's the one that started in that
stupid-ass movie called the elephant in
the living room
now if he knows anything about animals
you'd notice first thing is
you don't set out in the [ __ ] woods
with a noose pole
trying to catch a mountain lion what do
you expect him to do just
walk up and put his head in the [ __ ]
noose
but what he has done is he's conspired
this little thing with the united states
department of agriculture that i'm
dangerous i got banned from the big cat
symposium that they put on up there in
kansas city because
i'm so called dangerous i am far from
dangerous for any kind of law
enforcement agency or the government
but i'll guarantee you and all back up
his promise
a first time wayne pacelle and he is
[ __ ] nuts
or carol baskin or peta crawl this fence
and try and hurt any of my animals again
you can guarantee i'm gonna put a cap in
your ass the first time
to make you squirm around on the ground
and then i'm gonna put a
right between your [ __ ] eyes they
burned me down once
you politicians and you governors and
all these other people that make laws
need to understand that these
[ __ ] are crawling in the fences
at night
at facilities just like mine and
poisoning the animals
and burning [ __ ] down march of 26 they
crawled in our park while i was
gone at a funeral overnight in chicago
and they blew up my alligator house in
my recording studio these are problems
that everyday americans have
thank you
americans have i
unironically and unapologetically
[ __ ] love this man
carol baskins is a criminal and she
should be doing the time this is
this is i'm sorry i [ __ ] love this
guy
yeah killed seven alligators and one
crocodile burn that [ __ ] to the ground
we got one of them [ __ ] on
videotape and to this day
nothing has been done to it you know why
because we had a federal agent standing
right there in the office here a while
back
and tell us that they would not
prosecute peter because it's too [ __ ]
political
now we got a problem here in this
country when we have somebody that's
been declared
a domestic terrorist that is too
political to prosecute
when the hell is it right to crawl in
somebody's place
poi he's not wrong about anything he's
saying no he's right
again i i not i know people think it's a
bit
but i love joe exotic animals burn [ __ ]
down
walk on sidewalks in california anywhere
else in the country
and throwing red paint on people just
because they choose to wear a fur coat
there is nothing free about this goddamn
country anymore it's all about who you
are
and who you know let me move on to a
senator by the name of john
thune you know the worst thing you can
do is lay in bed and the alarm clock
goes off and
i hate when my alarm clock goes off yeah
when you get an alarm o'clock
the alarm is clocking over the place
yeah it wakes you up the today show's
playing and
all you see is mayhem murder and
[ __ ]
and when i'm talking about [ __ ] i'm
talking about the politicians and the
[ __ ] that's going on in america
now we're gonna have some senator named
john thune
that's gonna introduce some bill to make
it illegal for a business to be able to
sue somebody for putting a false review
on
yelp or trip advisor let me give you a
little education mister first of all
you people up there in washington and
this white house and the senates and the
congress and everything else
you need to work four years and then you
need to get out and get a real [ __ ]
job
so you know term limits he's calling for
term limits
this is why they arrested him this is
why i'm telling you based and he was
still close to why they were
a revolution because what happens next
time he ran for office and he got
[ __ ] 40 percent of the vote how do we
know he wasn't he's not q
now what's going on in the business
world in america
let me tell you something i've been
self-employed for over the last 35 years
and i'm out here in the real world and i
know it's right or wrong or bullshitter
you can scoop up with a scoop shovel
you know what the problem is with online
trip advisor and yelp and all that
[ __ ] first thing is is you fire an
employee
and what do they do they get a vendetta
against you so they get on the internet
and they post all this negative [ __ ]
about your business it's right
online that's right and you can't get it
off of there ruining american jobs
he's actually right the second thing is
you got people just like that rescue
facility down there in florida
and the global federation of animal
sanctuaries it's all [ __ ] jealous of
what anybody else is doing
and this is all about getting donations
shoved over to your facility if you can
badmouth somebody else
so what do they do they get all their
employees other volunteers
and all the people that like them online
to go over to your
trip advisor and your internet sites and
start putting bad reviews on there that
jesus christ your animals are starving
your cages are dirty the place looks
like [ __ ] the people are look i've been
to the big cat rescue let me tell you
something that place looks like [ __ ]
yeah the one in tampa i'm not saying
joe's exotic joe exotics was great
at all but the big cat rescue was a
[ __ ] mess
that place was a [ __ ] mess this is
what they took from us america
this is what they took from us they
locked up a guy for telling the truth
while carol carol baskins allegedly
killed her husband and fed him we need
to free
the tigers free this man donald trump
trump party if you don't
i already said this and i meant it when
i said it even though it was kind of
kidding if if trump gave him clemency
or gave him a pardon he'd have my vote
that's all you need
because the world's ending anyway so you
want my vote trump you want me to
campaign for you
free joe exotic and i'll [ __ ] vote
for you
american i love him i i just i know
cause i've gotten some emails and [ __ ]
from people
they're like it's a bit right like that
guy's a piece of [ __ ] and i'm like
i i like him i know he's a piece of [ __ ]
but i like him